my compadre from nfl game day morning
and pro football hall of famer
michael irvin how are you irv rich i'm
doing great rich
i'm i'm happy and looking forward to
this little show we're about to do yes
and i can only be this happy seeing the
movement knowing
that my guy will not be moving that's
right i understand what i'm saying
tcb taking care of business and i was
saying it does
you know what i mean uh you know
obviously it matters how much jerry
jones you know
paid for dak prescott uh if it takes
away from the rest of the salary cap but
they actually lowered his number for
this year when the number's lower so
maybe they'll be able to make some hay
but
you know as somebody we just heard again
in our peacock only segment for those
might have missed it on our radio show
uh you telling uh a story about jerry
jones making you laugh when he was
telling you no about uh
a contract uh for more money and
what what do you think how should dak
take it when he sits next to jerry who
says that
uh he anything that's ever been worth it
he's overpaid for
how do you think dax should take that
comment
michael well if you've heard jerry
talking i'm sure
jack jack has heard jerry talk many
times
you know un honestly many times he's
always used that analogy
when anything he thought had great value
because he said he'd overpaid for it
it still means he says it has great
value
that i would overpay for see we this
thing goes both ways
you know and then he also said that
always
have proven to be a good thing
to be a good thing so absolutely i
i don't know i i wouldn't be taking that
as a slight especially
since he just paid me a hundred million
millis over the last
two years 30 that year last year
at 75
settle down just a little bit there it
goes it's jumping in i know what i'm
saying right
there y'all know what let me tell y'all
this man and it's funny dog i'm not
rich i was with stephen jones i mean dad
jerry we're all at a party a couple
years ago at the super bowl
right and we're all hanging out and
stephen of course we had now i had a few
innocent
hanging out steven said why you know
what michael michael anderson
we were talking about that prescott he
said man you know one day
one day if he continues down his path
i'm gonna have to write a check
for 200 million dollars to him i said
come on
200 i thought he was crazy basically he
just wrote hitchhike
for 200 million dollars it's incredible
it's incredible now comes the hard part
though because
now um now that he's been paid like this
and uh the team is going all in here
uh with he and cooper and
zeke uh chewing up uh
uh a chunk of the cap to say the least
if not a quarter or more than a quarter
on this team and just three players
where where
do the cowboys rank going into 2021 i
know that free agency hasn't landed and
the draft
hasn't landed yet but you know what the
level of expectation will be
what's their what's what's their
expectation in your mind
we're looking at cap hits available
cash under the cap dallas has already
made
i think significant improvement by just
going back
to what they did before on defense
making that decision in the off-season
on the style of defense that you'll go
back to playing you know
i i think that's going to make a huge
difference
and and you talk about the pressure
that's put on that
rich i'm going to tell you something you
know and everybody you hear
talk about i that that's how he performs
that that's the best place and that's
how he performs
so i'm not worried about that either i
i'm looking forward to it and it does
change once you get that money
once you get that kind of money oh my
god you just
got you got you got to be god on the
football field just about
and that kind of pressure will be
sitting on dax back and and i can't wait
to see
how he answers the bill because he has
always
answered the bail all right so then
let's get uh specific then
since you just uh uh did not
um nfc east you expect them to win that
20 21. let me tell you something it was
a shooting
i i i i listen i was like it's over are
you joking
i was telling stephen aiden it's over
the nfc they'll win that and rich no
joke
washington and i started saying 30.
why'd he do that because i'm just
telling you i'm telling you listen to me
ryan says magic and take that stuff he
does
over to washington and and and they can
get somewhere and do something
i'm a little worried about that yeah i'm
a little worried about i don't blame you
i respect him enough
that that that's a possibility right
there that that was a move
that just didn't i didn't like too much
i bet i
bet you know and uh because you know
with that defense and
you know obviously he might turn it over
a little bit more than what ron rivera
would like but you mean
you know the way he's going to try and
jam it in the window to mclaren and
logan thomas and the the running game
and
um i i would be concerned about that but
you still think
shoeing for dallas in the nfc east okay
so then let's go
higher up let's go higher up uh do you
think with dak
being resigned dan quinn being brought
in to run a defense that you think is
more
um you know familiar with the personnel
and i think that
a lot of people were saying that was a
big problem with their defense last year
um and you know we'll put aside why
dallas even considered that
um to begin with but that's the past so
now what about
um green bay do you think dallas is
better than green bay
going into 2021 just first blush right
now
i think dallas will play a good game
with green bay in the playoffs
absolutely with a chance of winning that
football game absolutely
okay especially with this with the
offensive line that we'll get back
the guys that are healthy but also the
guys that step
in now they have that experience so when
to be the backup so if these guys tyron
does hold up you got somebody now with
some sustainable ability
to back it up absolutely i do okay uh
let's go further up the flow chart then
the tampa bay buccaneers you're
defending super bowl champs
who you who you were so all over in the
super bowl as if you were all over them
for all
26 weeks that's okay that's the past we
can forget about that too
uh the buccaneers do you think the
cowboys are going to be better than the
tampa bay buccaneers in 2021 first blush
as we're sitting here right now that now
the dax in the fold
and you know there's some more draftees
etcetera coming
and here's the issue here here's his
situation there okay
you know because because you you want to
put it out
as if you got me in a corner here with
this but let me tell you how i feel
i don't understand where you're getting
that from i don't know
dallas has the physical talent
that that that even playing with a few
bad decisions
within a game can still take over
and beat the green bay packers and move
on
now here dallas also has the physical
talent at least offensively
offensively because if that line is
intact
that'll slow down those guys up front
the physical talent to compete with
tampa bay
but it would have to be the perfect game
the perfect game in order for them
because tom
isn't going to make many mistakes so so
so that's how i would drop that answer
now the question could be could they get
to the perfect game
and i i'm you know hey i'm willing to
see
well obviously that could definitely
happen all right um so should i even ask
you about the chiefs or you're going to
accuse me of trying to box you in here
but you know no no the keys are good too
they they they did they
you know i found it how everybody's
reacted
everybody's reacting to what just
happened in 19 that's what
so so that first few the first day is
like
we're going okay you know what he ended
our season last year
we're going at the first thing we're
going after and the chiefs
and we talked about tackles and fisher
being out but what really ended it
was they came right up the middle of
that field
and and and patrick mahomes had nowhere
to go
you know sometimes even the tigers you
still uh
get a pocket that he steps up in right
and then well you know
so he gets five steps backwards or seven
steps backwards
and a few steps forward and that's all
it takes i reached here way past you by
the end
it's over but when you do came right up
to middle
when he came right in the middle they
couldn't even do that and they
solidified that
by stealing the patriots michael irvin
here uh on the rich eisen show this
this uh tweet caught my eye i don't know
if you saw it if you
if you if you didn't uh i can describe
it for you as we put it up on the screen
it's deandre hopkins tweeting out a
photograph of him looking very happy
in a cardinals uniform and it's his one
year anniversary mood because it was one
year ago today
that he learned that the cardinals were
acquiring him from the texans
and the first thought i had
michael was to also ask you about this
is how do you think
that's playing in the phone or timeline
of
desean watson today in the middle of
free agency right now
what do you think michael right that's
what i thought yeah
that's rich or is that a leap is that
too much of a leap you tell me
yeah i tell you but what you're saying
is
how much did that strengthen his
position for him
as he sees this you know when he said
okay i'm willing to do what it takes
even if i have to
take it to that tenth level you know or
the twelfth level
that's after the clock strikes me
strikes midnight you know where i
[ __ ] out and stuff how much is he
willing to give to
have that and not go back
to what he had so yeah
yeah because i mean i i'm sitting here
thinking because you're
you're you're seeing it you know what
what what it means you know when old
school
general managing or old school
management um
certainly when they think that they
bestowed upon you
uh a contract worthy of your talent in
terms of money and security and
no trade clause that you know when
battle stations come to it that
eventually you know right now we're
saying you know what there's no deadline
until the draft
anyway free agency's not that big of a
deal and then if the draft comes and
goes and there is no trade
then all of a sudden this sends things
in a totally different
realm where you're going to force the
player
to choose between his money and his
principles and then
when that happens things can go
completely sideways
um and again seeing uh a photograph of
his teammate
uh his all-pro teammate from back in the
day now teammates with another one of
his all-pro teammates
from the houston texans that was just
you know allowed to walk free you know
and we understand that
over there well i know and that they're
both there now
i i just saw that and and i'm really not
trying to stir anything up
i'm trying to give real talk here about
how it might land in the palm of
someone's hand to see that photograph
you know yeah yeah and i'm telling you
rich but just like you said they know
there's something down inside of desean
also
and i say that their approach has been
you know i don't know i don't know what
they could say publicly but if i if i'm
them i'm backdooring
all the other players you guys got to
call the show
you gotta have a look because he's more
apt
to bend to them to his other players to
the other teammates
than he is to management
so i'm going to play if i'm on that team
i'm on that team man i'm a movement
i'm gonna move in and be talking to him
trying to figure it out to help
to help that situation right i think he
is shocked if it comes from players
but no shot all right coming from
upstairs are you are you
are you getting set to suit and boot for
the show right now is that am i hearing
closet doors open and close is that
what's going on yeah i'm moving from one
to the other rich you know as i'm
getting dressed rich i like to
try to get some curls works in you know
trying to work out some that's why i
built the gym here but
then i moved to the studio to get ready
to talk football
while i'm getting my curls in my abs and
you know of course i'm watching the
shows and
preparing and studying and everything
like that i understand [ __ ] but
you so what's it here so are you trying
to get swole before
appearing in a suit is that what you're
saying to me i don't know i don't
because i i don't understand i mean are
you going to show up in the hockey lease
medium on nfl network
no no but but but but the feeling rich
you're just looking at the outer casing
yes
what really radiates the outer casing
is the inner man so
that gets me in that moment okay like
i'm about to go
right now all right all right erv well
you go you go ahead you know i know you
got to get ready for everything and i
appreciate the time right here and
you know i really wasn't trying to box
you in on anything you know i'm just you
know that
the clock's ticking here i mean uh jerry
jones was on the show before the 2020
season just at the outset
um saying that he asked the he said that
he asked the good lord
uh when they had when you had just two
trophies that if if if
if you uh bestow us for the third i'll
never ask for another
and now he's admitting i'm asking again
you know like literally is what he's
saying i mean time is short here he's
got to get this thing done
right now with these guys that's what
i'm saying yeah you know and
and and jerry knows you know at the time
he made that uh god understood how
important it was
but god's a forgiving god too not really
he's a forgiving god
he says jerry come back begging he can
forgive jerry
and let him win another one that's all
i know he made that promise but he could
forgive him
and let it win another because that's
what we'll have a chance to do right all
right just tell it
okay i don't have the patience jack
okay the greatest i i can't wait to see
what comes out of that prescott after
going through all he's been through
just the stories of it i'm telling you i
love the journeys i can't wait to see
what comes out of it i'll see at the top
of the hour on nfl network michael
thanks for the call
absolutely buddy right back at you
that's michael irvin hey you watched all
the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here